if these images of long empty hallways
and abandoned shopping malls seem
familiar you may have come across the
aesthetic trend of what is known as Lial
spaces empty or abandoned places that
often appear Eerie forlorn or surreal
they are also known to capture moments
of transition an in between period that
is typically marked by uncertainty such
as the New
Year limal spaces are this emotional
phenomenon uh that's not about a space
it's not about a place a time or a thing
it's about the emotions that are that
are triggered by seeing something or
smelling something or potentially
remembering something that brings you
back to a really pivotal time in your
life
but there's something eily wrong about
it or there's something missing where it
causes you to kind of question uh how
you got there or what you're doing there
whether you should be allowed to be
there if you're
safe ACC in the early' 7s this term
describes the transitional in between
places of daily life such as hotel
hallways airport walkways or office
corridors the aesthetic grew popular in
2019 after an online post about U Back
rooms went
viral further gaining traction during
the pandemic with the empty abandoned
public spaces
worldwide by the end of 2023 ainal
spaces subreddit has nearly 700,000
members and has inspired everything from
video games to the TV show
Severance to bring these places to life
bookbinders started experimenting with
exploring these Lial spaces offline by
organizing Community walks
[Music]
I've been exploring Lial spaces before I
knew what Lial spaces were so I've
always been attracted to the aesthetic
but when I saw the name it was kind of
like oh yeah it's this thing that I've
been chasing for a very long time
definitely didn't expect it to be this
popular a lot of people came I think
that's really cool um finding or or
meeting so many people that have a
similar interest in this weird thing
that's like such a
Purgatory
feeling we kind of feed off each other
and we share things that we wouldn't
usually share it allows us to tap into
memories in real time that we couldn't
actively remember so I think it's a
beautiful experience
[Music]
together and why are so many people
drawn to Lial spaces for this
torontonian it's
simple I have a very strong Comfort when
it comes theal
space I feel like I've returned to my
childhood I feel like I've regained an
ounce of Innocence because these These
are the Aesthetics these are the colors
the form factors that I grew up around
and um having a restored sense of
innocence and childhood is probably the
most anyone could ever ask for and I
think it's really the same emotion we're
all feeling but we're all expressing it
and processing it in different ways
Katherine Chang Global
News